tout de suite l'invité de Paris direct
[Musique]
et nous recevons ce matin Martin 15
c'est bonjour merci d'être avec nous
vous êtes directeur adjoint du bureau
parisien du GMF German Marchal food of
the United States nous allons revenir
avec vous sur le discours de l'état de
l'Union de Joe Biden le premier du
président américain depuis son élection
une allocution devant les élus du
Congrès dans un contexte compliqué ou de
la vie pandémie de covid 19 et puis
guerre en ukraineur d'abord cette
question toute simple comment est-ce que
vous vous avez trouvé Joe Biden a-t-il
été convaincant on va revenir dans les
détails après mais juste cette première
impression ou pas convaincant je l'ai
trouvé très traditionnel finalement on
est dans une situation de guerre une
situation assez exceptionnelle et on a
eu un discours qui commence avec
l'Ukraine mais qui ensuite est devenu un
discours de politique intérieure
américaine classique pour un discours de
l'Union qui parle aux Américains de
leurs problèmes en vue des des élections
de mi-mandat dans 8 mois finalement pour
ceux qui attendaient une sorte de grande
vision de du monde et de la guerre en
Ukraine on a eu quelque chose d'assez
alors cette gare en Ukraine il en a donc
parlé les élus du congrat américain se
sont quand même levés pour une ovation
au peuple ukrainien au début du discours
ils étaient aux couleurs de l'Ukraine le
président américain il a assuré que les
États-Unis étaient coté du peuple
ukrainien il a parlé de Vladimir Poutine
comme un dictateur qui est le plus isolé
que jamais je vous propose de l'écouter
puis je vous ferai le dire juste après
les fondements même du monde libre
pensant qu'il pourrait le faire plier
avec ses menaces mais il s'est trompé de
calcul il pensait pouvoir renverser
l'Ukraine et le monde avec au lieu de ça
il a rencontré un mur de force qu'il
n'aurait jamais anticipé ou imaginer il
a rencontré le peuple ukrainien
alors on l'a entendu il a quand même
insisté sur cette unité cette unité non
seulement des Ukrainiens des Ukrainiens
mais aussi des Occidentaux il a utilisé
cette formule du monde libre qui est qui
a été forgé également pendant la guerre
froide
il a connu depuis sa campagne
présidentielle
Joe Biden essaie de structurer un peu
ses grands enjeux géopolitiques autour
d'une opposition entre les démocraties
et les autocraties la guerre en Ukraine
pour lui et l'illustration du fait que
le monde libre qui inclut l'Occident
mais pas seulement fait face à une sorte
de compétition de la part de régime
comme le régime russe mais également
chinois iranien donc finalement cette
guerre c'est la confirmation de ce qu'il
avait déjà dit avant et tout le long de
ce discours ce qu'on a vu c'est que Joe
Biden se rattache à ce qu'il avait
promis il y a maintenant plus d'un an au
peuple américain et a souhaité leur dire
j'avais raison à l'époque continuer de
me faire confiance il a tu es rassuré je
crois qu'il y avait une phrase assez
intéressante quand il dit nous serons ok
ça ça ira finalement il a voulu aussi
leur dire que les États-Unis avaient
travaillé pour la liberté avait
finalement eu un beaucoup de succès dans
cette capacité à créer des coalitions
face à l'attaque russe et enfin il a
essayé de montrer que aujourd'hui
Vladimir Poutine était celui qui était
dans une situation de faiblesse alors
que on le voit sur le terrain ce n'est
pas vraiment le cas donc on a eu un
discours qui était très optimiste qui
était finalement celui d'une nation qui
devrait se sentir en confiance alors
même que sur le terrain évidemment la
situation est très différente Olivier
finalement ce discours de Joe Biden il
était pas en tout cas sur le côté
ukrainien il était pas à la mesure de ce
qu'on attendait disons qu'il a été
relativement classique il a rappelé les
principes de la posture américaine
c'est-à-dire qu'il n'y aura pas de
troupe américaine qui iront en Ukraine
pour se battre il y a néanmoins un
engagement total des États-Unis pour
soutenir les nations les alliés dans
l'OTAN voilà et un des régimes de
sanction qui vont continuer à s'étendre
pour ils ont contré l'action russe
néanmoins il n'y a pas de réponse à la
question qu'est-ce qu'il se passe si
l'intensification du conflit continue si
on voit une escalade dans la violence
dans la violation des droits de l'homme
Joe Biden n'a pas finalement proposé une
vision pour le futur du conflit qu'on
sait sera très long et très violent
américain à tous les vols russes la
création d'une tasse force pour
s'attaquer aux oligarques c'est quand
même des annonces qui assez forte sont
les annonces fortes néanmoins on est
tous je pense à la fois en Europe et aux
États-Unis conscient que cela n'arrêtera
pas Vladimir Poutine donc sont des
agences qui des annonces et les
sanctions qui sont nécessaires
stratégiquement évidemment il est
important de montrer le soutien de
l'Occident vis-à-vis de l'Ukraine mais
on ne peut pas répondre à cette question
qu'est-ce qu'on fait pour arrêter
Vladimir Poutine aujourd'hui en Ukraine
ça il faut l'avouer nous sommes
finalement et c'était le point du
discours hier nous manquons de moyens
nous manquons de levier pour
véritablement arrêter l'invasion
à une impuissance des pays occidentaux
pour répondre à cette question au futur
les sanctions encore une fois sont
nécessaires ne sont pas suffisantes et
si on attendait de la part de Joe Biden
de proposer peut-être une des options
autre nous avons vu qu'il n'y en avait
pas et là encore c'est pas forcément la
faute Joe Biden c'est simplement que les
États-Unis comme l'Europe se retrouve
bien impuissant face situation on va
parler maintenant du volley qui était
également très attendu c'était la
politique intérieure il est revenu
notamment sur la la pandémie de covid 19
on l'écoute encore une fois et je vous
laisserai agir juste après
est-ce qu'on peut dire qu'il sait
montrer quand même plutôt optimiste face
à cette crise un peu pour dire que ça y
est le covid commence à être derrière la
nation américaine très optimiste le
contexte c'est celui d'un président qui
connaît de gros problèmes dans les
sondages qui a une élection de mi-mandat
absolument crucial dans 8 mois et donc
il est important pour lui de montrer un
que son bilan de cette première année
était vraiment positif et deuxièmement
qu'il y avait de l'espoir pour le futur
aujourd'hui il y a environ 70 % des
Américains qui considèrent que les
États-Unis ne vont pas dans le bon sens
que la dynamique n'est pas bonne et on
compte donc lui il voulait montrer une
image différente ou l'administration
byden a réussi à répondre aux principaux
enjeux de la de la classe moyenne
américaine l'inflation la question de
des coûts notamment médicaux et enfin de
la crise du covid
sur le terrain ce qu'on voit c'est que
la plupart des Américains qui sont
interrogés pensent que l'administration
Maiden n'a pas fait assez c'est ça que
Joe Biden souhaitait contrer avec ce
discours hier faire cette liste
d'actions qui ont été prises depuis 12
mois et dire continuer de nous faire
confiance continuer nous faire confiance
en novembre lorsqu'il faudra voter lors
de ses élections puisque nous faisons du
bon travail
justement à Joe Biden de de remonter au
niveau de sa cote de popularité qui est
environ à 37 % selon un dernier sondage
un dernier sondage de BBC de toute façon
les élections sont encore dans 8 mois
beaucoup de choses que ce discours ne
marquera pas un tournant clairement dans
la campagne qui a déjà démarré on le
sait également ce qu'on a pu voir de de
d'accord entre républicains et démocrate
autour de la crise ukrainienne parce que
c'est vrai qu'il y a eu une forme de
d'unité parfois sur cette crise reste
très superficiel et très vite on verra
des batailles reprendre le dessus
l'unité qu'on a pu voir hier lors de
l'ovation pour l'ambassadeur ukrainien
ne résistera pas aux batailles à venir
politique intérieure américaine c'est
propositions pour convaincre l'inflation
à un moment il en a parlé notamment de
produire plus aux États-Unis est-ce que
c'est c'est viable est-ce que c'est
viable sur le long terme
parce que même si les républicains ne le
disent pas ils sont en fait d'accord
tout ce qui concerne le le les
investissements pour renforcer la
compétitivité américaine ramener les
emplois aux États-Unis ramener des
industries aux États-Unis c'est un point
qui est bi-partisan en Amérique les
républicains ne donneront jamais cela
comme un succès de Biden mais on peut
imaginer que cette politique
industrielle va continuer quel que soit
les résultats des élections dans les
années à venir même en 2024 quel que
soit le prochain président
programme de dépenses sociales ni sa
profonde réformes du droit électoral qui
était censé protéger l'accès des
Afro-Américains aux urnes il est en
difficulté vous le disiez comment est-ce
qu'il peut faire la pour s'en sortir ces
prochains mois alors pour lui et c'était
un point important
dans le discours hier c'est qu'il
montrait du doigt le Congrès il est prêt
à signer les lois les lois ne passent
pas n'arrivent pas sur son bureau parce
qu'elles sont bloquées au Congrès et
donc il souhaite mettre devant au pied
du mur les législateurs démocrates ceux
qui ont parfois bloqué un certain nombre
de ces initiatives en leur disant si
vous ne me donnez pas des législations à
signer nous allons perdre dans 8 mois on
le sait ça n'a pas fonctionné cette
espèce de
cet argument n'a pas fonctionné durant
la première année on verra à mesure
qu'on se rapproche d'élection et que
potentiellement une défaite apparaît de
plus en plus clair si un certain nombre
de sénateurs démocrates qui ont bloqué
se reviendront sur leur choix et
donneront des des victoires à adjoba
la peur de la défaite c'est ça qui va
obliger les démocrates à travailler
ensemble il y a au sein même de ce parti
comme dans tous les parties différents
courants ils n'ont pas réussi à
s'accorder sur les grands plans de de
reconstruction des États-Unis sur les
enjeux notamment climatiques sur les
enjeux sociaux avec une frange beaucoup
plus progressiste qui souhaite aller
plus loin et souhaite que les
investissements soient bien supérieurs à
ce qui a été proposé et à l'inverse un
certain nombre de sénateurs qui bloque
en considérant que il n'est pas
nécessaire de dépenser autant et surtout
pas danser domaine là on verra si la
peur de la défaite suffira à réunir un
peu ce parti
merci beaucoup Martin cassé d'avoir été
avec nous rester avec nous sur France 24
dans Paris direct tout de suite à un
nouveau journal une demi-heure une
nouvelle demi-heure d'informations avec
une dame tout de suite
[Musique]